déclaration d'urgence à washington ça se
ferait ce soir tout après la fin du vote
sur ce projet de loi très spécial qui
permet d'éviter une paralysie des des
bureaux fédéraux à washington et à
travers les états unis madame monsieur
bonsoir bienvenue de m 4 x 100 en fait
faut bien le dire c'est que dans notre
europe emploie les grands moyens pour
réaliser son rêve construire son mur à
la frontière du mexique alors en
décrétant l'état d'urgence ce soir ben
si vous l'avez entendu un par les
réactions
c'est une mesure exceptionnelle qui lui
permet de débloquer le financement
nécessaire afin de détourner des fonds
pour y arriver il est contraint selon
lui d'agir ainsi faute d'avoir obtenu
des compromis des démocrates dans les
négociations budgétaires mais cette
décision provoque une levée de boucliers
à washington on parle déjà de
contestation devant les tribunaux parce
que le président a vu six de ses
pouvoirs exécutifs présidentielle avait
à mes côtés à montréal les abeilles
valait chercheuse à l'observatoire sur
les états-unis de lucas bonsoir
elisabeth évidemment une grande
spécialiste du mur et de toute la
question américaine et avoir shelton
notre correspondant que s'arrêterait
avec qui je commence avec vous un
christian cours de soirée cruciale
critique on s'y attendait on en parlait
aurait-il l'audace de déclarer l'état
d'urgence n'est pas quelle heure ça va
se faire parce que ça va être toujours à
la chambre des représentants ce moment
mais il y en parler tellement hilare
devant la défaite face aux démocrates
avec cette entente là email lui sa
menace à exécution
c'est ça oui on ne sait pas encore si le
président va se prononcer ce soir et
déclara ce soir l'état d'urgence
anne-marie on se garde une petite
réserve parce que ça risque d'être
plutôt demain monsieur de chambre va
peut-être choisir de laisser retomber la
poussière et occuper tout l'espace
médiatique qui sera nécessaire demain
pour rendre son message très clair et
faire une déclaration comme quoi il n'a
pas laissé tomber ses partisans il n'a
pas laissé tomber sa base il va tout
faire en son pouvoir pour aller chercher
l'argent nécessaire et est complétée ce
mur et vous savez monsieur de chant pas
très bien joué ses cartes
il a en quelque sorte forcé mitch
mcconnell a publiquement
appuyez monsieur choï mais cette femme
ne lui a pas laissé le choix monsieur
mais quand même on n'était pas du tout
en faveur d'une déclaration d'urgence ou
aux états unis il l'a laissé entendre à
plusieurs reprises mais monsieur de
chambre lui a probablement dit si tu ne
m'appuie pas publiquement
je ne signerai pas cette loi et ce sont
les républicains au congrès qu'ils
auraient porter l'odieux d'une deuxième
fermeture du gouvernement en quelques
semaines seulement
donc en ce sens cela monsieur choï a
très bien joué c'est qu'à seulement on
s'attendait pas à ce qu'il a ce qu'il
déclare ou est ce qu'il ose déclarer
l'état d'urgence et c'est toute la
question de la légalité maintenant qui
est qui survient et évidemment
éventuellement on va devoir définir ce
qui l'urgence parce que il ya plusieurs
présidents qui l'ont déclaré avant lui
on pense pour catherine à cet ouragan en
nouvelle orléans au lendemain du 11
septembre des cas d'urgence évident mais
en ce moment plusieurs personnes et moi
même je me suis rendu à la frontière et
on n'a pas vu d'urgence la même les
militaires qui s'y trouvaient se tourner
les pouces
alors y'a pas d'invasion les gens la
majorité qui tentent d'entrer aux états
unis passent par les points d'entrée
officielle
ouais bah évidemment on entendu les
démocrates madame pelosi a 10 ans et
demi je pourrais donc contester cette
déclaration devant les tribunaux si
c'était une alternative c'est plus
qu'une alternative je pense qu'ils vont
ils vont le faire ils vont devoir pour
éviter qu'à l'avenir les pouvoirs
présidentiels quelqu'un abusent des
pouvoirs présidentiels vraiment définir
ce cadre parce que c'est vrai qu'il y à
des articles de lois qui ont été votées
d'ailleurs par le congrès et qui
permettent au président de décréter ces
mesures d'urgence mais c'est quand même
assez bien encadré alors on se demande
là et c'est ce qu'ont à part au congrès
le savait
l'article 1 de la constitution
américaine est très claire les cordons
de la bourse sont contrôlées par les
membres du congrès c'est eux qui elle où
les budgets c'est eux qui votent
l'argent et en ce moment ils ont un peu
l'impression d'être contournée pour de
fausses raisons et on se demande comment
ce que monsieur jobs va aller chercher
ce 23 milliards dans différents
départements dans différentes agences
pour des raisons politiques finalement
d'accord 23 milliards c'est beaucoup
d'argent c'est plus que le 5 7 milliards
qu'il voulait avoir dans une entente il
est bête christian vient de le dire
c'est le congrès que le pouvoir de
l'argent les potes de postes et par le
pouvoir du porte-monnaie oui de prendre
de plus comme disent les on le dit en
anglais alors cadre et pour nous ce
pouvoir d'urgence exceptionnelle dont on
dit que ça pourrait être un abus ici de
pouvoir exécutif en fait le président
dans la période moderne post 45 s'est
retrouvé au dans un monde qui était un
monde nucléaire dans un monde nucléaire
si la corée du nord a appuyé sur le
bouton on ne peut pas aller discuter
avec les représentants et les sénateurs
puissent branché sur le fait de s que
c'est approprié déclaré la guerre donc
très vite on a vu tout un tas de pouvoir
comme ça qui ont permis au président de
mobiliser très vite là le feu nucléaire
mais dans certains cas d'avoir le droit
de déployer l'armée rapidement c'est
c'est la loi sur les pouvoirs de guerre
d'avoir le droit même de donner à
l'armée le pouvoir de construire des
bâtiments militaires des fortifications
militaires extrêmement rapidement
c'est une partie des lois qui pourraient
être utilisés par
donald trump en dix ans on a besoin
d'édifices militaire de défense donc ce
que pourrait être le mur alors c'est ce
pouvoir là a du sens lorsque le jeu est
joué par des gentlemen c'est à dire
qu'on respecte minimalement les le cadre
de l'état de droit et qu'on admet qu
effectivement c'est dans le cadre d'un
désastre naturel qu'il faut mobiliser
pendant un temps des pouvoirs qui sont
des pouvoirs qui relèvent d'autres
d'autres compétences en l'occurrence le
congrès ce qui se passe ici c'est que le
président va s'appuyer sur une série de
lois qui sont prêts existants qui donne
au président le pouvoir en cas de
désastres naturels en cas d'urgence en
cas de d'attac d'aller chercher du
budget ici et là de redéfinir en fait
les l'orientation des fonds le
secrétaire à la défense peut aller
chercher du budget qui sert à de la
construction par exemple de la
reconstruction à porto rico et le faire
glisser vers le mur donc c'est vraiment
ce genre de pas seulement nous sont les
mecs qu'elle a dans la pop et ils
murmurent il y en a aucune chasse est
manifeste c'est une dépense qui est
extravagante pour quelque chose
question l'a dit pour lequel il n'y a
pas d'urgence c'est là où est le
problème est qu'un papier vous cette
semaine n'y a pas d'urgence et de toutes
les autres d'urgence aux états unis et
il y en a beaucoup mais cette urgence là
n'existe pas le problème c'est que
lorsque nancy pelosi ou l'aclu ou
d'autres organismes ont porté ça devant
les tribunaux le juge va se retrouver
confronté à une chose c'est la
qualification juridique des faits est ce
que c'est une urgence et il est probable
que si dans un premier temps les cours
vont dire on suspend l'application de
l'urgence le temps de statuer
ils vont en arriver à la conclusion de
dire que ça n'est pas à eux de
déterminer ce qui est urgent ou pas
c'est un rapport entre le congrès et le
président et que le congrès a poussé
vers le président un certain nombre de
pouvoirs c'est à lui de les reprendre
c'est ce qu'on appelle la doctrine de la
question politique lorsque le juge dit
au fond ça ne devrait pas être réglée
par jour ça devrait être réglé par le
congrès et le président on ne s'en mêle
pas en même temps avec le stand a vu
lors des audiences pour le juge kavanagh
que c'est un grand défenseur de des
pouvoirs exécutifs un peu d'ailleurs
comme le nous
vos procureur général aux états unis
mais un volet amber aujourd'hui c'est
alors l'idéologie au pouvoir c'est de
soutenir des pouvoirs exécutifs très
important pour le président oui mais
encore faut-il qu'il soit comme dit
elisabeth très très bien défini et ce
sera intéressant lorsque les tribunaux
entreront dans le débat de voir si par
exemple aurait des injonctions est ce
que parce que les tribunaux discutent de
la question tente de déterminer ce
qu'est une urgence est-ce que par le
fait même monsieur deux chambres sera
obligé d'arrêter de dépenser l'argent
sera obligé d'arrêter les travaux au mur
ça je pense que ce sera une étape
importante parce qu'il qui ce qu'il veut
en bout de ligne monsieur job c'est de
tenir promesse il a promis ce mur il a
tenté de négocier que le congrès écoutez
il est parti il est parti de 25
milliards qu'il demandait aux mexicains
durant sa campagne présidentielle de de
payer pour le mur et il s'est retrouvé
cette semaine avec 1,3 milliard c'est ce
qu'on appelle une défaite politique
sévère et ça monsieur jobs n'aime pas
perdre
hélas le fait qu'aujourd'hui il annonce
par la voix de sa secrétaire de presse
que probablement demain il lui a déclaré
l'état d'urgence c'est ça étonné bien
des gens on pensait pas qu'il les laisse
sortir ressortir ce lapin du sud du
chapeau mais en même temps koné semble
le seul job et son avidité à toujours
vouloir gagner on ne passe vraiment s'en
étonner
et pour vous et les bêtes c'est une
véritable défaite de tschopp et prend sa
revanche avec ses pouvoirs d'urgence qui
est ce qu'il pourrait en payer le prix
ah c'est ça c'est une bonne question
c'est quand même un président en téflon
on a remarqué qu' résister quand même
beaucoup de choses je pense qu'il a une
volonté christian a raison de ne pas
perdre la face de reprendre le contrôle
de l'agenda
c'est un élément exemples comme ça avec
l'état d'urgence
l'immigration le péril migratoire
jusqu'à présent au moins dans sa base
lui a vraiment très très bien servi et
qu'ils veuillent remobiliser cet
argumentaire la reprendre le contrôle
aussi autour de cet argumentaire là
n'oubliez pas que tu aimes pas rempli le
dossier pour sa réélection le jour de
son investiture donc lui a les yeux sur
2020 et 2020 c'est vraiment c'est ce
dossier qui lui a réussi dès le départ
c'est celui-là sur lequel il table
quel qu'en soit le coût et le coût est
extraordinairement et
mais les républicains vont suivre là
dedans en voit que les républicains ont
un peu peur
ils attendaient de voir si le signerait
pour savoir comment ils se
prononceraient là on voit déjà un
repositionnement par rapport à l'état
d'urgence
il y a un coût politique encore
aujourd'hui on aurait pu penser que ça
aurait pu s'estomper avant il ya encore
un coup politique à se dissocier à se
distancer de donald trump et on voit
d'ailleurs les décisions de trappes ne
se positionne pas par rapport au congrès
normalement dans un rapport normal de
régime présidentiel on devrait avoir un
rapport congrès président cela il se fit
beaucoup en fait le quatrième pouvoir
c'est fox news ce sont les médias
d'extrême droite serge limbo asean
clôture ce sont eux qui vers lesquels en
fait qu'il constitue le véritable
contre-pouvoir aujourd'hui voit en tout
cas une caisse de résonance qui allait
récupérer un mot en terminant très
rapidement un christian elizabeth
confirmation donc de william banques
comme a tenu du rôle d'un comme
procureur général qui va avoir un mot à
dire sur le rapport de l'enquêté mme
müller on a au moment où aussi où on a
pas que l'ancien directeur mais qu'eads
du bia et qui a été très brièvement
aurait aurait eu des discussions y
aurait eu des discussions sur l'état
mental du président après le
congédiement de commerce que toutes ces
histoires le passé sous le radar avec
cette histoire de déclaration d'urgence
oui plutôt oui à washington où
effectivement d'ailleurs l'entrevue
monsieur coup mais pardon de monsieur
mais qui sera diffusée à cbs à 6 min
dimanche là ça fera probablement les
manchettes le lendemain quoi qui est des
extraits qui ont commencé à circuler
ce sont surtout intéressant du côté de
monsieur bart de voir jusqu'où il ira
quand le rapport moral silva par un jour
et publiée on se demande ainsi un jour
la rédaction finale va aboutir on verra
bien mais s'il va le rendre public et
qu'est ce qui le rendra public
je pense que c'est ça qui inquiète déjà
personnes pauvres
oui absolument rouler en bas à une
lecture de la constitution qui est une
lecture analogues aux juristes sous de
beaulieu gauche au moment de la torture
il a d'ailleurs justifié le fait que la
constitution avait des limites son
applicabilité qu'on n'ait pas à
l'appliquer en d'ordre par exemple à
guantanamo qui est en dehors du
territoire américain donc une vision
très extensive des pouvoirs de
l'exécutif à une heure où on a un
président qui paraît prêt
atout pour mobiliser ses pouvoirs au
delà de ce qu'on avait vu jusqu'à
présent en temps de paix rdse du congrès
pis aller jusqu'en cour suprême
rappelons que la balance des pouvoirs
mais pourrait encore évoluer si votre
pas de ginsberg
si je peux me permettre il pourrait y
avoir un retour des choses en faveur des
démocrates par exemple si monsieur de
chambre utilise ses pouvoirs
sait-on jamais le jour où les démocrates
reprendront le pouvoir à la maison
blanche peut-être des quatre le
président démocrate va décréter que il y
à aussi urgence pour les changements
climatiques - 6 est donc ce sera
intéressant de voir comment ce que les
république et à ce moment là et pas à
percer des exemples du papier
d'elisabeth cette semaine dans le devoir
merci beaucoup à christian bonsoir
évoquant même succès de près ce soir et
demain merci à vos questions à
washington